every YouTube creator or while almost
every YouTube creator is faced with a
catch-22 of sorts a pair of conflicting
interests on one hand you have YouTube's
discovery and ranking mechanisms for
which key data points are linked to
stuff like percent viewed likes shares
and subscriptions on the other hand you
have the need for a peer relationship
with the audience or at least the
perception of a peer relationship
the first encourage is a strong call to
action openly reminding your audience to
LIKE share and subscribe
but this boldface self-promotion is
openly at odds with a sense of
approachability since it pulls back the
curtains so to speak and reveals the
underlying asymmetrical mechanics of the
relationship so how to resolve this
dichotomy well there's no one way but it
gives us a good opportunity to explore
the mimetics of advertising by working
through one possible solution this
solution is revelation through
obfuscation in other words we're going
to reveal the mechanism we're going to
pull back the curtain but at the same
time we're going to put up as many other
curtains as we possibly can in order to
distract from the curtain that we just
opened up yes my friends were going into
the whoa begotten lands of irony and
self-deprecation all right down to brass
tacks how are we going to ask you the
audience to like share and subscribe
while making it palatable we're going to
turn it into a joke this joke will make
it seem funny like we're putting
distance between us and the incentives
that are acting upon us however the
underlying operative and actionable idea
will still be introduced into your mind
and the notion of interacting with that
idea will be recontextualized as an
extension of the joke and this means
that you will be more likely to like
share and subscribe so with all that in
mind what if we played off the almost
mantra' like nature of like share
subscribe and amped up the almost
cultish reverence like share subscribe
like share subscribe well that could
work what if we tried outright
repainting it with existing religious
iconography do you have a few minutes to
talk about another Testament of like
share subscribe
mmm maybe not the flavor that we're
looking for so go in peace my children
in the name of like share and subscribe
amen
all right I think we're on the right
track let's take that one and combine it
with the Snuggie monk go and peace my
children in the name of like share and
subscribe
amen that's some pretty solid
obfuscation with a double bonus of
creating a bacon atmosphere of community
visa vie spiritual initiation there's no
accident that many of the largest
YouTube creators have special names for
their community and followers the
foldable army team foldy but this is
where it all risks turning into a
quagmire it's really easy to get bogged
down in cynicism seeing the same actions
that are so often coldly exercised by
massive corporations and describing the
same disengaged profit motives to people
who just want to entertain others the
lines get really blurry was it the
chicken or was it the egg are we in a
space where sincere individuals are
adopting and adapting the exploitative
mechanisms of corporations in order to
succeed in an environment where those
are the rules of engagement or our
corporations hijacking the emotional
structures of authentic communities in
order to sell more soap why not both how
do we tell the two apart where's the
line where one grows into the other and
is it even possible to engage
authentically with another person
through a displace in a symmetrical
medium like YouTube is our cynical
resistance to the idea of being a
marketing demographic breeding and Arab
irony that serves to do little more than
prevent us from engaging with content in
an authentic manner building a wall of
feigned indifference that serves only to
separate us from our true selves even if
opening up would leave us vulnerable to
being exploited by the capitalist
systems that we inhabit and in
suggesting that we allow ourselves to be
vulnerable am i serving to cut through
years of defensive baggage for our own
good or simply serving the needs of a
capitalist hegemony by priming you to be
more receptive to incoming messages that
is quite possibly something for each of
us to decide on our own but I would
caution you to avoid becoming too
cynical we all need to do what we need
to do to get by and sometimes that means
dressing something distasteful but
necessary up in a stupid costume in
order to make it dance for our amusement
so go in peace my children in the name
of like share and subscribe amen